ومن الرياض ينضم الينا الباحث الاجتماعي
الدكتور عبد العزيز الكلب للحديث عن عشرات
الملايين في جمهور الفنون والترفيه يعني
في الماضي كنا نتحدث عن الرياضه وكره
القدم فقط كيف تقرا هذه الجاذبيه للفنون
والترفيه البعض وضعه الترفيه والرياضه في
فئتين مختلفين هل الفصل منطقي
الله يعطيك العافيه وشكرا لك انا خليني بس
اخذ مثال حيي انتو قبل شوي جبتوا لنا عبد
الجواد من روسيا وقفز في الماء البارد
نسال عبد الجواد ليش فعل هذا الفعل طبعا
للمتعه هو الترفيه دخول الماء او حتى لو
تشوفوا كان يلعب بالكره الماء مع بعض في
الماء البارد وهذا امر طبيعي البشر ترغب
في ان ترفيه ترغب في المتعه هذه هي الحياه
مبنيه على جوانب كثيره وعده ولولا اختلاف
الاذواق يعني في كثير من الجمهور مع زال
يعشق كره القدم وفي المقابل ايضا هذا
الجمهور يتوجه الى وسائل الترفيه الاخرى
مثل الفنون وغيرها ولكن ايضا هناك جمهور
للفنون خاص وخرج لنا هذا العدد الان لما
اتيحت لهم هذه الفرصه
نعم
دكتور
دكتور عبد العزيز رد اسالك يعني هل تعتقد
انه اختلاف الديموغرافيه السعوديه اليوم
انه هناك جيل اكثر من الشباب اثر على هذا
الموضوع
طبيعي جدا نعم فئه الشباب تميل
للفنون ولممارسه الرياضه في جانب اكثر
والمتعه بالنسبه للشباب جزء منها هي
الترفيه ولذا قد نجد فعلا انه الشريحه
السكانيه اليوم في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه من فئه الشباب في الغالب تهتم
وعملت على زياده هذا العدد وهذه الاعداد
ما هي نتيجه ان وجدوا هؤلاء الشباب
والشابات وسائل للترفيه غير الوسائل
السابقه التي كانت موجوده او تحدهم عليها
يعني نعود لمساله الفصل بين الترفيه
والرياضه استاذ الرياضه ترفيه ايضا هل هذا
صحيح
طبعا الرياضه نعم ترفيه ولا يمكن الفصل
بينهم لانها كلها جزء من الثقافه الثقافه
هي كل متكامل يشمل الفنون بكافه اشكالها
سواء فنون شعبيه او الغناء او الموسيقى او
المسرح ايضا الافلام او الرياضه في الجانب
الاخر فاذا لا يمكن الفصل بينهما في جانب
انهم كلهم ادوات ترفيه وكلهم ادوات ثقافيه
في المجتمع
فعاليات الترفيهيه مقابل ثلاثه ملايين شخص
فقط يزورون اللي هي نقول المباريات كره
القدم برايك كم هذا يدعم السياحه اليوم في
السعوديه خصوصا هناك توجه
للدعم هذا القطاع بشكل كبير
طبعا عمل وزاره الترفيه والمتابع للساحه
في المملكه العربيه السعوديه عمل وزاره
الترفيه عمل جبار بكل تاكيد سيجذب مجموعه
من السياح من مناطق عده وسيزداد هذا العدد
وانا اتمنى فعلا انه في السنوات القادمه
تزداد فعاليات الترفيه هناك فعاليات لم
تدخل السوق بعد السعوديه نتمنى فعلا اننا
نشوفها ان شاء الله في العوامل القادمه
بكل تاكيد هذه الوسائل سوف تجذب ايضا عدد
اكبر من السواح سواء من خارج المملكه من
الدول القريبه او حتى من الدول البعيده
وايضا من داخل المملكه للمناطق التي تكثر
فيها المناسبات الترفيهيه الباحث
الاجتماعي الدكتور عبد العزيز الكلب كنت
معنا من الرياض شكرا للمشاركه
[موسيقى]